it is all science data rich data cold
data your happiness your strength your
help is up to you what is your choice
hey guys welcome to a brand new season
of the bow show this is change your mind
change your life you're coming here
because you want to see the most
inspirational people in the world doing
what they do best and you want to
distill their knowledge take it for
yourself and run with it so I've got
someone who has changed more lives than
I can even imagine the incredible Iceman
wim HOF and I'm not doing an intro
because we don't know who this guy is
you've probably been living on the moon
but alone musk would have sent you as a
vice documentary that showed you that
but guys wim Hof's with us wim thank you
so much for joining us today right-oh
bow thank you for having me amazing
amazing crazy yes well I was telling
when just before we got on here how
people can change other's lives four
years ago I got into this fear of
interviewing people and wanting to
change the world I reached out to
everyone with my heart and authenticity
and wim was the only person that said
yes and he gave me a chance and I used
it and it opened every door and now
we're here we're talking to Gary Vee
we're talking to Tony Robbins David
Goggins you name it it's amazing so
thank you in from me it's without you I
wouldn't be here man it must be that I
recognize this soul power of yourself
I appreciate that especially coming from
you someone who I can't describe is the
closest thing to a comic book hero there
is ha ha
let's marvel the world so what I'd love
to know is so we both we've seen the
documentaries and hundreds of interviews
but it's been about seven years since
you started to get really big and one
thing that I'd love to know is how how's
things changed in the last seven years
for you have you have your techniques
adapted developed shortcutted has
something changed for you yeah it's
amazing you know in the end it's just
about breathing so the t-shirt it's as a
brief
and that as simple as that is is the
mind and now it has come to the
understanding both of me and of science
that it is not complicated to take full
power over your own brain deceit of the
mind and to enter into the threshold of
owning the unlimited power of your own
mind that has come in the last seven
years to my understanding that it is the
time to do it
that be awakening and their time to wake
endure and that the people are ready
they already fed up with the past it's
it's over this is the time where we take
over our own mind in the end it is the
most logical thing to do learning how to
own our own mind because the mind is
beautiful do you feel beautiful than you
or your mind do you feel beautiful and
you are attaining beautiful goals then
you own your mind
if not then breathe so I know that um
I've seen and it's been a beautiful
journey watching the what started out as
you breathing and people come to see you
to the wim HOF method and now you've got
the app and everything and I love your
three pillars of breathing cold exposure
but the third one's really interesting
the third one's commitment and that I
was not expecting that many like when I
found it out but realizing that that is
such a key pillar and that's one of the
things that I've seen in the last seven
years with your work change that you've
got this look it's all good to go and do
it once and then just run outside into
the snow and back but it's a commitment
it's a lifestyle and I'm I can
definitely see that change but how have
you found that people are accepting you
and more accessible to your kind of it's
not radical anymore but you're extremely
open view that we are way more powerful
than we perceive ourselves to be recent
studies showed that the power of
the power of intention is all decisive
within us able to tackle stress and it
showed any Michigan study which I did in
Detroit in brain scans enabling me just
by the power of thought making skin
temperature not going down while being
exposed to ice water
that means ice water is like aggressive
ice water is like the the equivalent of
pure stress coming to you and just by
the power of thought being able to make
it make these skin temperature not going
down what is that that is the I'm
showing what everybody has is the innate
capacity to rule over stress just by the
power of your own conscious will and
taught this is what I've been showing
and always somebody needs to begin and
start with something out of her belief
out of intuition out of the God and here
I stood up and I told the professor's ok
test me go with me into brain scans and
I will show you what the power of
thought really means so the mindset
commitment that is learning to attach
and to connect with the true power of
your own beautiful mind the true power
of your will the true power of your
thought to be able to be all the sis's
to work and against any type of stress
and that is a new era that is new in
psychiatry where depression and
psychosis and bipolar and PTSD and all
are like and we cannot do anything
against the gel you have to take pills
and medicines no you have to learn and
now it's there
to own your own beautiful mind and this
is the way we are not schooled to be
happy strong and healthy
we are not schooled in those things we
have been learning about history
mathematics and language but not
happiness strength and health that is
the hormonal system that is the the
immune system the vascular system all
ruled by our power of our mind but we
have been into mathematics and one and
one is two and three and three and you
have to come up for your position in the
world and now the economy is is bursting
open and nobody is happy anymore come on
man we have a power to be unconditional
in love with life and we don't need much
we need it all and all is within the
unlimited power of our own brain we
learn to own our own mind and to bring
all that is complicated this is what the
professor's say wim HOF has found the
secret of placebo that placebo it was
somewhere there but now we are able to
connect consciously with the power of
healing and healing means that what is
inflicted and the result of stress could
be an impact could be bacteria virus
emotions mental stress doesn't matter
all that needs a certain kind of control
through our brain the seat of the mind
and our ability to control dust distress
in whatever shape it come it always in
the end is cell biological stress and we
have a mind thought which is very subtle
in which enable to ask to neurologically
sent all to the cell and stabilize what
is out of being out of control
deregulated and and that is a new
understanding the professor and they
have shown this and have published it
called its court
down-regulation whereas before this was
not possible now it's there our
neurology is growing so much we make
iPhones and and it's amazing how much
bytes and how much possibilities go in
an iPhone this iPhone is more invites
than the whole Apollo project in 1968
then a project it went to the moon and a
Neil Armstrong with a big step for
humankind blah blah blah blah right now
that neurology has grown and now is in
an iPhone more than the whole project
done that is the fruit of our minds the
fruit of our consciousness and neurology
and that neurology we are now able to
make the step to control to control that
neurology and use it not as as abstract
as the placebo but to use it consciously
to heal ourselves from any kind of
stress just by thought and that is the
new Wonder standing that's where I am
this is about a commitment to me d
complicate it all and to make it simple
you are born to be happy strong and
healthy when a person is in control over
his happiness like unconditionally he is
not going into war he is not going into
achieving so much more power he's not
going to possess more and to gain more
that system is into power it's like the
second best but I say the first one the
best of the best is who you are and what
you have within your control to be happy
strong and healthy and this is what we
give to the people you're talking like
at the base foundation I I think you see
it all the time because you're so well
known so many people come to you for
this shortcut like they want to keep
their life as it is but then add like a
wim HOF cherry on top and that's gonna
take them there but they're not
realizing they need to go to the base
exactly penny yeah
you're talking serious just like it so
electric it's like I need a portable wim
HOF with me haha yeah yes we need to
make portable what what is ours
and we have we are going to the moon we
colonize other countries we are into
politics and power everywhere in the
world we took over the natives
properties and all and that we think hey
this is all ours no you know what is
yours your happiness your strength and
your health
well you got that you don't go somewhere
else and wherever it went wrong I think
it was about with the time of the
industrialization whenever when a
extension tools began to take place and
we began to look outwardly
more and more and more and and now we
are taking over the world we took over
the world we destroy nature polluting it
sodomizing it and becoming insensitive
to each other where is the love where
where is that what is most valuable for
our children that is love that is
happiness that is strength that is
health and we cannot guarantee it and
this confusion we need to stop now we
need to awaken to our neurology and this
time it's there I've proven in science
that we are able to get into deeper
parts of our brain ever thought possible
this could not maybe happen 50 years ago
because the fruit of our neurological
growth i poach and all that is reflected
in our brain our neural activity is
about 10 times more than in the Middle
Ages then in the you know in the
medieval times it is more and we do not
understand this yeah now we have come to
a point where we have and we are able to
awaken to a control over our inner
neurology of the brain the seat of the
mind and get a hold of the unlimited
power
of the mind driven by love cuz what
would you do if you are in love if you
are happy and then you love it you love
it what do you do when you see your love
on the other side you you're not gonna
think is it good what is love and maybe
I should do this yes or no the
consequence no you want to fly you wanna
go and that's the feeling of life should
be we should love life we should be in
control over our happiness our strength
and health and that is the love I want
to pass to my children to all the people
because you my brother and we are all
one family and that with that family
which is in love we automatically will
respect nature and it's all coming back
and this cycle of love is making the
world say a same place for the future is
where the soul is residing the way the
soul is there is no fear when there is
the soul the soul is are breakable
everlasting then we have fulfilled the
purpose of human erase within the cell
within the primordial purpose of the
cell becoming conscious and now we are
able to become fully conscious hundred
percent control over the brain we have
shown in brain scans doing these
breathing exercises it is that at will
we create 100 percent neural activity
flow at will that we that means we are
able to change the chemistry inside the
brain the neural activity so the blood
flow plus neural activity and thus we
are at will able to suddenly enter into
any part of our brain that is one study
I did in ANOVA in Germany with the best
brain scans of the world and that in
Michigan I showed in brain scans how to
just by the power of my thought just
thinking
hey I don't want my skin temperature
going down while being exposed to ice
water ice water is aggressive
it just gets out to you you can't do
anything that's the paradigm but I
showed very clearly robustly activating
the deepest part of the brain which was
considered to be inaccessible and had
suddenly activated like 100% and then
the temperature of the skin never went
out and they were like flabbergasted and
then they said this is a
transformational technique that will
change mental healthcare what do we
suffer right now with a lot of
depression unemployment aggression
brutality all the system doesn't work
anymore the system should work to
deliver happiness strength and health
and prosperity and in harmony with
nature not exploiting and sodomizing it
to be in harmony with it struck by or
everyday that you are our life that is
spirituality with two legs on the ground
with the neurology we are able to
control that's where I go I love it you
talk about the unlimited power of the
mind and since you've been doing this
for so long
are you still finding there's things
that you're learning about yourself and
your own power or are you pushing
yourself because I know that you teach a
lot but just judging for your
personality you're always gonna be
looking for something deeper something
more powerful surround work but
something more controllable within that
we thought was incontrolable right now
I'm doing a study with the University of
San Francisco on the D and Age on the
DNA and it shows that we are very
successful able to alter the DNA more
than before was thought possible
very soon we have the outcomes with the
best top researchers in America in the
USA I think that that that is exciting
I am always learning for more to
discover more me for myself I can
yesterday I was like
for one hour in the ice is great strong
exercise very amazing oh wow
I felt good yeah fully in control but my
real control is I could do so much more
but my real control is to bring
happiness strength and health to my
children to my families to you to the
whole world and the understanding that
time of love has arrived that is where I
want to proceed and I become very strong
before I die which never will happen the
soul will be present it's like the
mystery will be there intact understood
and logic it's there to be unrevealed by
the power of our own mind where we are
able all of us individually to recognize
that the soul has come to full bloom and
it brings happiness strength and health
it brings the solutions to the world and
brings harmony it's all in there mother
nature is gonna gotta be there so what I
love is you're like this modern Shaymin
for anyone who wants to access you so
it's not like we have to trek through
woods and jungles just to find you you
are openly available however you also
blend it with just common sense and
science so it's not just an opinion and
one of the things in the past I remember
people saying is we're all capable of
this and that just brush it off saying
yeah but Wims a freak of nature and
stuff and the longer I'm on this planet
in this industry but developing my own
health and hearing others there are more
and more people doing phenomenal things
like you and one story is a very good
friend of mine he on his 50th birthday
he was diagnosed with lymphoma and
leukemia was told he had weeks to live
on the just on the anniversary of his
30th wedding anniversary his wife
dropped dead of a brain aneurysm and he
was just about to give up and through
that tragedy he decided you know what I
don't want to listen and he went on and
with active cancer he swam the longest
river in Oregon the Willamette in
sub-zero conditions for 21 days straits
set a world record his doctors now
believe that they may have misdiagnosed
him because the cancer Prytania so we
mentioned they call it always magical
it's like yeah it's a lightning struck
so he learned about you after that and
then he went on to swim the longest
river to Ireland raised thousands for
charity and then he's from the eel River
and we're making a documentary about him
in hopefully January in New Zealand he's
60 years old now cancer-free wants to
show the power of what you're doing
swimming the longest three rivers in New
Zealand back to back and showing how the
cold is our teacher wow that's amazing
bless him all I love to him and the
power and you see how effective it is
and what I do is bringing signs in so
all the remor you know all the
chattering of the mind stops because
non-speculative
evidence-based proof is what the world
needs in the Western mind it always
keeps on going going and it never stops
into being silent in peace and in
confidence it's always there somewhere
always out there out there out there
well the peace and the love and the
power is within us the soul is within us
and it's time to stop this gathering of
power and going outward this is the time
to go inward and to see that it is not
difficult and that you don't need to do
supernatural things that the
supernatural the unconditional love is
already there and that the d
complicating that aspect that's what I
do through signs showing that everybody
is able to do this when I showed the
people seven years ago in the university
after sixteen thousand and one hundred
and thirty-four people becoming sick in
a experimental model
of being injected with their bacteria
e.coli which normally make people sick 3
to 6 hours in that model then I took a
group of people I trained him in four
days to have the same experiment to go
undergo at the same same experiment and
they all the 12 people they did not
become sick that means after sixteen
hundred and sixteen thousand one hundred
and thirty-four people becoming sick of
that model so everybody
then suddenly twelve people did not
become sick what did they do they went
inward they followed the breath the
breath is the life force they followed
it with their will their consciousness
stop the breath at the certain moment
change the chemistry stopped it and then
the bacteria at no chance suddenly they
had connection with the deepest of their
physiology which was the immune system
which was the endocrine system the
hormonal system and they reset it at
will their bodies through their will and
their breathing that made a fundamental
change happen inside because up till
then it was never been shown that the
autonomic nervous system the endocrine
system immune system that could be at
will influenced now it was not
influenced it was deeply being activated
and deeply being controlled and this
changed signs fundamentally only this
world is about a dependency is about
selling pills selling medicines
pharmacies hospitals psychiatry Asylum
it is a sick world where people want to
gain money over the suffering of people
they don't care it's insensitive this is
the paradigm it came from the past and
let me tell you right now with the
inability
oh all the medical science to deal for
example with the corona virus I tell you
we have the power within to deal with
the corona virus bacteria depression we
got it all and I got it all
endorsed by non speculative evidence
based proof science that's what I love
about you you are here you can't be
argued to it there was an amazing story
about the journalist who tried to debunk
you and then became one of your best
followers yeah yeah he's preaching the
gospel everywhere now at this time it's
not a religion it is sighs there is no
speculation guys no philosophies
it is all science data rigid data cold
data your happiness your strength your
health is up to you what is your choice
well I know a lot of people are gonna be
so excited listening to this and they
might want to click off this video to go
and try your breathing to get into that
space but you're gonna stay here guys
because I spoke to him earlier and I
said can we do just one round of
breathing so you can breathe with us and
just experience this I do this breathing
all the time and it's transformed my
life I can't remember the last time I
was sick so women if it's okay with you
do you mind if we do around wow yeah
yeah sure man and listen what happens
with this breathing it changed science
fundamentally in its principles of what
we are able at will to do within our
physiology and that is amazing now
feeling is understanding hey so get into
this relax rely a relaxed body is able
to open up in the deep tissue there we
are
you got your values your belly and then
you chest to may have a full inhale like
this
and they let it go Fuli in him let it go
Fuli inhale let it go I'm gonna set up
the Tyler who little let it go inhale
fully let him go
become lightheaded loosely the body
tingling all alright guys nothing is
happening more than carbon dioxide being
blown off keep on going fully air
there you go we are becoming alkaline
now the pH level is rising we are
changing our chemistry right now keep on
going
Fuli as simple as it is as deep as it
goes foolish
lerigot anything that you feel different
here breathe into it
your mind is with one thing that is the
breath julio letting go follow the
breath follow the life for us because we
are talking life force we are going to
deeply manipulate we are going to become
the alchemist changing the chemistry
inside to the level of the DNA to the
level of the brainstem the deepest part
of our brain to the level of the bone
marrow all there the breath it's like
water
it goes everywhere Fuli changing the
chemistry rule let it go turn off don't
mind follow the breath fooling it go and
pool yet go whoo
oh five more foolin whatever you feel
deep red make it stronger even don't
mind fall oh god right three more fully
in letting go one more food en let it go
how comes the last one
Fuli is let go after the exhalation stop
close your mouth there we go the witness
be the witness there is no force needed
you don't need to breathe your body is
alkaline we change the chemistry
it's very alkaline only when the
alkaline is low we need to breathe now
the alkaline is high up we change the
chemistry what now happens is that the
oxygen is gonna drop drastically that
means that the deepest part of your
brain is going to be activated the fight
and fly into danger yet you feel high
high on your own supply nice okay
relaxed but you are the alchemist right
now you are changing the cause of nature
that is consciousness that consciousness
enters in all cells through our will
neurotransmitters - electricity light to
all cells it goes we are changing
bringing purpose light to all cells and
5 4 3 2 1 food in hold and squeeze to
your head 3 2 1 and let it go there we
are
this is only one round
this changed signs fundamentally and
from here we are able to bring
electricity the nervous system into into
the cell into the DNA to bring
electricity through our will into the
ancestral trauma traumas of our
genetical coats encrypted codes we are
doing this study right now so it's no
speculation you want to freeze something
more than your own ego you go into your
DNA you freeze something that is hidden
within your cell we are born with
purpose to free anything that is inside
we are care we are the carrier of the
past to bring it to the present and to
free it forever that's the soul that is
who you are I feel so powerful I love it
it to get it it's it's like a it's
acquiring a superpower anytime you need
it yeah something that you mentioned
recently I listen I think you're talking
to Russell Brand and you were speaking
about the eight senses and I thought it
was fascinating and it could you go in
because the most of us think that we go
we have to six and that's it but as we
know you're you're proving with science
but you've been doing this so long and
so many other people are seeing it how
do we go from six to eight yes I tell
you this is since the last study I did
within brain scans showing top-down a
regulation of the eighth neurological
network called
the Intel reception so you got the sixth
sense the sixth sense is like intuition
to comment from the subconscious we are
able through the autonomic nervous
system control to get into our
subconscious to imprint it with what we
need and to have these subconscious
enabling to manifest what we intended it
to do
is the sixth sense then you get these
seven cents which is another a
neurological network it's the call to
the proprioception big word for
something like what is the place in this
world in this universe that is balanced
physically but spiritually it's the
balance to know who you are and what you
are here for that is proprioception only
we had no control over that
yes limited control like physically
maybe mentally but spiritually it was
always abstract and now we have shown
how to enter into that deeply so far it
is related to the healing power of ours
that is the immune system now the immune
system has three levels it has the
direct our skin the saliva the Eider
ducks that is the first line of defense
then you've got the second line of
defense that is the innate immune system
which is a big problem right now with
the corona virus we have no control over
the innate immune system of response and
I say we have shown insights how to get
a control over the innate immune system
response we have shown this in the
comparative studies blood proof it's all
there so and then you got the specific
immune system specific immune system is
normally at work within five to seven
days five to seven days we'll say for
example with the flu virus and five to
seven days or 10 days that suddenly from
one day to another you are better
suddenly it's there that is the specific
immune system now that works after five
to ten days but we have shown to make it
work within a quarter of an hour by
being injected with the bacteria and
having within a quarter of our hour the
specific immune system up and running
detecting the
intruder there D regulator and make a
cell death apoptosis with that through
sending a protein gonna go on the cell
membrane of the intruder the virus and
it kills it specifically no inflammation
it kills it specifically and then is
that that there is need if you know
where you are there you know where to go
you got all the tools to heal yourself
and to keep on going within this
universe that is proprioception know
what you are really internally all about
and with that have a far deeper control
within the physiology of the mind and
the body that that is proprioception and
then you got in day reception number
eight the eighth neurological network
which was considered to be yes something
happens to you and then you react but
now you can make it happen
top-down and this was not possible but I
showed it in brain scans showing that I
was activating the deepest part of the
brain so if you are able wilfully to to
activate the deepest part of the brain
where else can you not go you know and
that is our innate capacity we are born
with her not with a lump of meat called
brain to be in control only 16% no
hundred and this is what we have shown
in brain scans in Germany with the best
brain scan of the world that they don't
want to look at it deeper everywhere in
the world is because we live in a sick
society
it depends all that money dependency of
people on the establishment the so
called
order the brutality I mean the wrong
order the system the system that is
killing the planet we need to
awaken to the full power within
ourselves we have learned too much what
is mathematics at language and history
all fine and how to position us within
the system but are we happy
are we strong and are we healthy because
those are the core values and that is
being jeopardized and there is too much
fear too much depression too much
disease too much confusion going on and
we say stop stop guys we are born with a
mind that we are able to control not 16%
100 and this we have shown in brain
scans and how is it it's very
complicated all the signs and all that
all the build-up and all the data and
it's just breathing the breathing and
your mindset instead of I cannot do this
I cannot do this they say yeah this
cannot happen
amen you are built to be happy strong
and healthy that is the right and a
rightful usage of your own brain the
deceit of our mind it's there number six
seven and eight
not only the five the the nasal their
eyes so that the feeling the touch and
the hearing know those are external and
then you've got the interior
neurological networks we have to stop to
go to the moon and to Mars and to Pluto
because Pluto is in the backyard it's a
dark and the dog is helping us where
girls when strangers come in and when
strangers come in hey no hey nice you
want a cup of tea nice tell me your
story huh instead of going to Pluto and
to the moon let's start being happy
strong and healthy and share the love
because there's plenty for everybody
one thing I love about you is you don't
care what anyone thinks about you and
it's this beautiful it's not confidence
its freedom and would you
say that some lot of people have social
anxiety and things and they put all
these labels on how they are would you
say that your techniques would be able
to create that emotional wellness as
well as physical wellness oh yeah no
it's all about emotion
you know after in the professor's they
told me this is a transformational
technique that will change mental
healthcare what is emotion emotion are
feelings that are really interactive
with our DNA with their genome
expressions and we have no control they
made us believe that our emotions that
the basic stones of life out of our
control and they never screwed us that
our happiness is within our control we
got the tools we are equipped to be
happy strong and healthy and when it
happens we are able to deal with that as
simple as it is and because we don't
believe in that that's why I go through
science and anybody any podcast any
person a president or disc or doctor or
professor i'ma drop out of school you
know why because it was not in the books
I went into nature and I come back and I
am changing science fundamentally and
science should show that happiness
strength and health are innate
capacities of every individual on this
planet and that they should learn to
exercise that learn about it from a
basic schooling in the primary school
even before and because that is the most
valuable of core values to give to your
children do we want to give in full
confidence happiness strength and health
then we have a ribbon to love in
confidence the power of love without
sentiment just the best there is and
then there is no graving for wars of
possession and sodomizing the planet
sodomizing people because a happy person
doesn't do that only and we are now
showing that there Gary
here's that and all the confusion has
stopped over there the confusion that
make people vulnerable to stupid ideas -
this is not possible this is not
possible you got to do this you've got
to do this look where it emitted up into
a polluted planet and if they keep on
polluting they begin keep on being
insensitive
you know the corona virus it killed
three three hundred seventy five
thousand people all over the world but a
hundred million people are going to
starve because of our Western economic
model they are going to starve this is
know it and it keeps on going man and
when when the world is on fire
the bush is out of play the Amazonas
apart Australians on fire nobody gives a
[ __ ] it's a billion animals are dying
species are exterminated and it keeps on
going this is the result of a system
what we are schooled it we should get
back to the court that we are built to
be happy strong and healthy let's get
back to our families
let's bring love to our awakened
neurology because we are able to do that
and I'm showing that in every scientific
new breaking through and solidifying a
new paradigm and this is what I do and
I'm a drop out of school but I'm able to
teach professors and doctors all over
the world they will not get to me with
their book knowledge I saw things in
nature my inner nature by going into
nature they they are not only incredible
it's arriving to one thing which is the
most valuable it's love love for life
love for my soul in full confidence and
there it is I'm sharing this and I keep
on going with the scientist until we
have all the proof that the soul driven
by love is the answer to and that is the
future so the emotion is one way to
happiness for every person in the world
well you and I we could chat for hours
and I would love that one day but
unfortunately I'm respectful of your
time and something that is really
evident is I get to speak to some of the
most successful people in the world and
the really great ones all have something
in common and you have it as well and
it's you are more motivated to add value
and love to others lives than to your
own and that is a beautiful thing you
and even there you just keep talking
about love and giving and you were the
most giving person I you it's you were
completely selfless that you just want
to make the planet better and make
everyone's entire way of acting better
just and you're offering your techniques
you're not forcing it down people's
throats so this adding value that you do
to others without the expectation of
getting anything back is one of the most
powerful principles I've seen across
every single person I've spoken to and I
think for me and the hundreds of
thousands of millions of people who have
encountered you in some shape or form we
all want to say thank you for that
because without you the happiness and
joy that we feel in different increments
around the day you have definitely
changed the world and I think we're only
getting started that's why we have you
on this platform yes but the reason we
have this platform and I work with Evan
to get these amazing interviews isn't to
get the likes isn't to get the views
it's to get the message out in louder
megaphone as possible so someone maybe a
hundred people watch and out of the
hundred one gets it or a hundred
thousand watch and to get it it doesn't
matter but we're gonna change your life
with this interview so win just thank
you so much for dedicating your life
because I know that you found this
method out of trauma after what happened
to your wife oh yes
and many people would go in but it would
then become like self like a magnet they
want everything for themselves but you
flipped it and you just gave and you you
used yourself as a guinea pig for the
benefit of everyone else so it's this
incredible trait and if you take
anything away from this entire interview
just look at whim and realize that the
secret to living is giving is that
simple yes it is that is the way to
trend stems to something greater
every time I reaching people I get these
beautiful healings I got people getting
off their depression people become happy
because of small things and big things
it is so it's blessing my soul I begin
to understand through others what the
purpose of life is it is love love and
love and it's amazing how I can wake up
every day and find newly again that
power we have to get rid of the mutt of
confusion and get love in front of us so
strong man man a man that's where I want
to be then there you don't need to
meditate you are just there and it's
amazing I feel blessed to have done this
interview with you because I'm gonna
watch it back as if it's a YouTube video
so I was here so I'm interning grateful
but just before we go what are you
working on right now I've already I'm
looking towards coming to see you in
Poland if the board is open next winter
because that's gonna be phenomenal in
person to do it but is there something
that you'd like to get a message out
into the world just to be like look this
is what we're doing and this is how you
can do it like I love your app your apps
phenomenal the wim HOF method app yeah
so I'm doing studies two studies are
being conducted now and being done they
are in progress new publications will
come I want to show that we are able to
get into say the bone marrow they're
consciously into the deepest part of our
brain that we are able to change mental
healthcare as it is fundamentally and
make people really happy
yeah like consolidating neurology
neurological pathways that makes you
able to control and to guarantee
happiness strength and health because
it's all in the unlimited power of our
brain only now we go past the placebo
and we get consciously in it and we make
pathways and then we are able to without
any
how do you say a sentiment to get in it
and to share it because when we are
happy the only thing you want to do is
to share to share it's getting more
because that's the nature of our soul
and that's where I want to go and until
and not it's not happening I just keep
on going every day he's a power and
there is more happening
I'm into going to climb to Kilimanjaro
in one day in shorts with people of all
ages and like the a woman is 56 57 now
that is the oldest woman and I'm 61 and
then you got young people from 20 and
like 30 people and we are serving with
that raising money for charity but all
to do science showing that we are able
to enter into those into physiology that
enables us to get into this healing
processes of our body more than
scientifically is stated and with that
we changed once again in a spectacular
way the paradigm and with that we serve
simultaneous a project to preserve
wildlife in Tanzania and a Kenya the
circle of life yeah that one and with
the Messiah we do this with the Maasai
they were yesterday it Chiefs came to
the Netherlands and we celebrate and we
talk about the tactics to show that we
do not need to have fear when we go with
the Rangers
they Masai warriors into the land of the
colour of the lion without fear because
that is who we are we are fearless
beings only we have we are so metal down
in our fears paranoia and confusion that
is that tourism we want to make in the
Garden of Eden and this is the project
we go for there it's coming sounds
phenomenal yes I'm gonna keep an eye out
because I'd love to join you
like that but guys this has been
phenomenal there's so much whim on the
internet but right I think you got so
much out of this interview so if you
want to rewind it and watch it again
there's an actual breathing with us on
this again go back and do it four or
five rounds if you want to know more
that we're doing on here just get over
to Instagram or even another YouTube my
YouTube which is at both um Hawkins and
we'll talk about some other things in
opinions but I'm so honored to have wim
here Thank You wim for coming on the bow
show I know Evan loves you so much and
one of our biggest videos on Evans
channel is house it never gets sick and
that's all thanks to you so wim thank
you so much for joining us today
all the love and power and keep on the
good works we are winning superstar if
you want to see the Boat Show interview
with Mel Robbins check out the link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there love that nobody's ever called me
that but I think you're right the one
thing I'll say is if you believe in what
you're doing don't sell it to somebody
self publish it